what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Rock or man Jason and Jason now y'all
know what's about act the baton yes the
button a conclusion of the button I
can't talk to you right now because I'm
in a hotel room I'm in Disneyworld
man imitation man I would not normally
stop going to Disney World to record
something but I will stop going to
Disney World to record the button man
let me tell you something if God was
right in DC Comics right now is what it
would look like right now this is some
of the best comic book writing that I've
ever seen that I have ever seen and I've
seen Jonathan Hickman write stuff I am
reading geoff johns green lantern right
now this is such a good story so in last
video we had picked up with the idea
that eobard thawne was finally caught up
to you
by Batman and Barry Allen the flash it
was almost like the events we're just
going to circle right back around to the
beginning right like it was back to the
scene where eobard thawne just kind of
showed up in you know the Batcave he
taunted that man they fought for a
little bit for like the span of you know
one second or something along those
lines
he disappeared reappeared ranted about
seeing God and then died this gives us
that cool moment and this is what I love
about eobard thawne this is one of the
things I love about his characters
eobard thawne is like fearless right I
mean he's arrogant and he has every
right to be this story confirms exactly
what we've been thinking that eobard
thawne is timeless in every sense of the
word
eobard thawne as we see him here is the
same eobard thawne that appeared in the
mark waved swords you'll mark waid flash
stories to return a barry hound this is
the eobard thawne from flash point this
is the eobard thawne from flash rebirth
before DC rebirth this is the same
eobard thawne that we've been reading
for years in years in years he's
arrogant he's cocky and it works but the
crazy thing about all this is that in
this moment it's Barry Allen trying to
reason with him right like it's Barry
Allen trying to say look good if you
keep down this path you're going to die
but it's the cocky nature of eobard
thawne coming right back to there and
saying you can't stop me I'm timeless
like I've been killed and I always come
back I am part and parcel to the
negative Speed Force I am part and
parcel to surviving I will always find a
way back and he always does but this is
the one scenario where he can't now
again the funny thing about waves and
kind of hitting back on the idea
this is the reverse-flash that we've
known for so long is when he starts
referencing the things that he did to
Barry Allen going back in time
manipulating his life so that he would
become the flash that was established by
Geoff Johns
during flash rebirth when Barry Allen
was first brought back prior to the
start of the new 52 and eventually DC
rebirth we have eobard thawne talking
about the idea of taking Barry Allen
going all the way back to the very early
days when he first became the flash
kidnapping him as a child raising him as
his own and making him an acolyte which
begs a question what would Barry Allen
look like as the reverse-flash
what kind of version of Barry Allen
would we be seeing in that particular
scenario but at the end of the day it
doesn't matter there's simply too late
you know eobard thawne arrives to the
destination of where the button was
taking him and this is when we find out
kind of who it was that he saw now the
way the Williamson does this is
beautiful it's so beautiful because all
we get is fawn just kind of talking to
this person saying hey look you remain
hidden from everybody
no one knows everything that you've done
but you can reveal yourself to me I'm
your friend you know I can't be killed
or anything like that I'm the one
constant if anybody can understand what
it is you've done with time it's me
give me the knowledge that you have and
this is kind of funny because Williamson
is playing it fast and loose here
because if you look the indication is
that Manhattan is in the button that
Ivar Thawne is literally talking to the
button now we as readers know that it's
not necessarily that way we as readers
know that for the most part this was
really just the button operating as a
key of sorts you know in the sense of
somebody grabs it it takes them to a pre
Dorit preordained location and they meet
dr. Manhattan and this is exactly what
happened with Ivar thought he meets
Manhattan but he's totally overwhelmed
by the power that he's seeing I mean
this is really kind of DC showing us
where dr. Manhattan stands in the realm
of his capabilities now the funny thing
about this is that along the way we get
this disembodied voice that's basically
saying Barry Allen was the key to saving
Wally West Barry Allen can save me too
all he has to do is listen now from the
solicitations when the covers were just
being issued out to everybody the
implication here was that it was Jay
Garrick and the question was going to be
how will we get Jay Garrick back because
keep in mind Jay Garrick hails from
earth-2 he hails from the
a jello Golden Age of superheroes that
universe which is earth to all the
original superheroes in the 1930s 1940s
even some in the in the early 1950s
that's all earth to when DC revamped
earth to in the new 52 Jay Garrick yet
we saw then was nothing like the one
that we saw now totally different
completely removed totally separate from
the character we were used to and so the
idea here is that the Jay Garrick that
we knew was just kind of lost in time
now this is not the first time that DC
has done this remember after crisis on
Infinite Earths there was only one
universe and so in order to bring in
Alan Scott in order to bring in Jay
Garrick those various characters that
had their run in the Justice Society of
America that JSA as it was written by
Geoff Johns they had to find a way to
roll them in into a universe that didn't
have a multiverse and the one universe
of the main DC heroes resided in so it
looks like they're going back to that
they're basically saying hey look we've
only got one universe here I mean earth
two that's already happened whatever
we've only got one universe here we have
to find a way to bring Jay Garrick and
that was my initial response that was my
initial thought and I was hyped to see
that but kind of jumping back here to to
eobard thawne the great thing about is
that he's just overwhelmed with power
and again this is really just DC saying
here's how powerful dr. Manhattan is I
mean here's just the level of strength
that he has something hitherto unseen by
eobard thawne and you gotta remember
eobard thawne's fought everyone eobard
thawne has fought to Justice League he
spots the flash he's fought some of the
most powerful beings in the DC Universe
and come out on top you know heavy
hitters like Superman so on and so forth
they're nothing to scoff at the fear
that eobard thawne shows here is
something that we've never seen this is
a childlike expression it's the
realization that he has stepped into
uncharted waters that he's called down
the beast and the Beast has answered and
it's far more than eobard thawne ever
expected and in light of this he
effectively loses his life now this is
kind of crazy
because in this moment Batman having
heard this disembodied voice of Jay
Garrick Barry Allen failing to pick it
up ultimately means that Jay Garrick
makes his presence known when Barry
finally acknowledges the sound of the
voice meaning that the memory of Jay
Garrick is now alive and well and Jay
Garrick survives only through memories
meaning if Barry Allen can grab this man
and bring it into reality then Jay
Garrick will very much be alive and this
is what we get now the reason why I love
this particular moment in this comic
book is because golden Golden Age
superheroes especially when they're
drawn by Alex Ross they invoke a kind of
emotion this visceral feeling that I can
never shake every time I see it I've
said it a million times before and I'll
say it a million times again there is
this amazing shot that Alex Ross drew
where you've got like the superheroes
running towards the screen you've got
Superman holding the American flag and
he's surrounded by all these other
Golden Age superheroes and it reminds
you of an era when superheroes were
truthful when there was no moral
ambiguity it wasn't well maybe we're
good guys maybe were bad guys there were
no anti-heroes there were good guys and
there were bad guys the good guys did a
good thing that bad guys did the bad
thing they fought the good guys won the
day was saved and that was it Jay
Garrick is a return to that Jay Garrick
is a return to this era when superheroes
walked a little bit taller you know when
they were a little clearer when they
just kind of made you feel hopeful and
that's why Jay Garrick's return here is
so significant the saddest thing about
this is that it's so short lives Jay
Garrick tries to pull the same road that
Wally West said or Wally West appeared
to Barry Allen said you have to remember
me if you don't remember me I will be
gone I will die that'll be the end of me
of course Barry Allen trying his best is
not able to do it but notice what
happens here notice what takes place
here Jay Garrick doesn't really die
first a loser doesn't seem to be the
case instead he's just immersed in blue
energy and whisked away and so the
indication seems to be here that Barry
was going to remember who he was Barry
was going to remember him and say oh
you're Jay Garrick I remember you now
but in that fraction of a second before
it happened Jay Garrick was whisked away
presumably by dr. Manhattan and that
begs the question is dr. Manhattan
building his own army is he building his
own superheroes his own villains to go
against the traditional DC superheroes
is that what we're effectively going to
see the Justice Society of America
versus the Justice League of America
with the JLA on the side of good and the
JSA on the side of dr. Manhattan it begs
that question what are we going to see
because I have a hard time believing a
Jay Garrick will be brought back as
popular of a character as he is among
the flash family and as many people have
been looking forward towards his return
I have a hard time believing that he
would be brought here and then just
prominently whisked away and that would
be the end of him but what this story
does as it starts to wrap up is it
basically looks at this entire event
from the perspectives of the flash Barry
Allen and Batman Bruce Wayne from Barry
Allen's ideology he basically says look
this case is far from over this is not
going to stop I'm going to keep trying
to find that you know trying to find out
who this person was that killed it you
bar Thawne because remember Bruce Wayne
and and you know very Alan they don't
know about dr. Manhattan they don't they
didn't see anything that eobard thawne
saw they don't know the Manhattans out
there all they know is that some just
wildly powerful force killed Vaughn and
whisked away Jay Garrick or at least
from their assumption Jay Garrick seems
to be dead basically kind of dissipated
that's really the end of him but the
other thing here and this is what's so
cool about this is that Batman reflects
in the words of his father where his
father says behind happiness do not be
Batman go and be a father to your son
leave that life behind because it will
only lead you down the road of anger and
sadness a life that's not worth having a
life that you really can't look back on
and find any small measure of peace in
and so in the moment when the bat signal
goes out and when Alfred asked the
question are you going to respond to
that Batman just kind of drops his head
and it looks like Bruce Wayne will not
be Batman is he quitting is he leaving
is Damian Wayne going to take up the
role so many questions are presented
here and so in this last little bit we
have dr. Manhattan picking up this
button and this is jaundice pupil this
is mama
monitors Wilma this is this is gorgeous
dr. Manhattan picking up this button
making this statement about how
everything is preordained
dr. Manhattan is a slave to time he
can't break time he can't violate time
we know that perspective from before
Watchmen dr. Manhattan
we covered that we talked about that
you'll find that link down in the
description dr. Manhattan's like look
everything that I say and do is
preordained I can't break away from Todd
I am as much of a prisoner of it as
anybody else's and so then the question
has to be asked is dr. Manhattan being
altruistic here is he doing what he
believes to be the right thing and if so
where does this road lead
happens with all of this it raises more
questions than it answers
dammit if this is not one of the best
stories has ever been written in DC
Comics but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like again I can't be
too loud here I'm in a hotel I can't
scream and shout otherwise I'd be crazy
hyped up about this but anyway guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and that will catch you
guys later please
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]